في تطورات الميدانيه قال مراسل الجزيره
انه سمع تحليق للطائرات الحربيه واطلاق
نار متقطع في جنوب غرب ام درمان هذا ويسود
الهدوء الحذر جبهات القتال بين الجيش
السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع في اليوم قبل
الاخيره لمده اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار بين
الطرفين الذي تم توقيعه في جده يوم السبت
الماضي
وكان وزير الدفاع السوداني الفريق ياسين
ابراهيم قد اعلن استدعاء المتقاعدين
العسكريين من ضباط وضباط صف وجنود لدعم
الجنود العسكريه
وشمل الاستدعاء بحسب بيان صادر عن الوزير
الضباطه وضباط الصف والجنود الذين لا تزيد
اعمارهم عن 65 عاما شريطه تمتعهم باللياقه
البدنيه والطبيه والقدره على حمل واستخدام
السلاحات ودع البيان من تتوفر فيهم الشروط
للتوجه الى اقرب وحده عسكريه اعتبارا من
يوم الاثنين القادم واكد وزير الدفاع ان
هذه القرارات تاتي انسجاما مع ظروف التي
فرضها التمرد حسب تعبيره
في المقابل اعتبرت قوات الدعم السريع ان
اعلان الجيش السوداني التعبئه العامه
وتسليح متقاعديه يعكس فشاله في ميدان
المعركه واضافت قوه الدعم في بيان لها ان
خطوه من وصفتهم بالانقلابيين تظهر بجلاء
ياسا وتخبطا من جانبهم الدعم السريع اتهمت
الجيش السوداني ايضا بمحاوله الاحتماء
بالمواطنين الابرياء للقتال نيابه عنهم
بدلا من المحافظه على سلامه وامن
المواطنين العزل حسب تعبير البيان
من شرق الخرطوم ما ينضم الينا مراسل
الجزيره اسامه السيد احمد اسامه اهلا بك
اذا ما اخر تطورات هذا الصباح
نعم ربما اخر التطورات بالفعل وفي هذه
اللحظات تحلق طائره حربيه في
مناطق واسعه من سماء سماء جنوب وشرق
الخرطوم
وتنطلق ايضا معها مضادات ارضيه تابعه
لقوات الدعم السريع في اتجاه الطيران
الحربي الذي يجوب سماء الشرق وجنوب منطقه
الخرطوم في هذه اللحظات طبعا
يعني هناك ايضا كان تحليقا لطيران الحربي
في منطقه جنوب غرب ام درمان كذلك بالامس
ايضا كان هناك تحليق للطيران الحربي
يعني هناك بعض
المدفعيه الثقيله في منطقه الشمال بحري
وفي تحديدا في منطقه الحلفايه ومضادات
ارضيه ايضا سمعت
في هذه المناطق اذن في هذه اللحظه كما
ذكرنا يجوب الطيران الحربي هذه المنطقه
التي نحن نتحدث فيها
والتطورات الميدانيه وفي اليوم السادس
للهدنه واتفاق وقف اطلاق النار ما بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في
مدينه جده هذا هو اليوم قبل الاخير يعني
صحيح انه لم يكن هناك اشتباكات مباشره ما
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في جبهات
القتال خلال الساعات الماضيه وامس واول
امس ايضا ولكن تستمر ايضا نستمع بوضوح
للصوت الطيران وكذلك صوت المضادات الارضيه
التي تنطلق من قوات الدعم السريع في هذه
الاثناء وتطورات موازيه ايضا كان هناك امس
بحسب مصدر اكد للجزيره ان
استخبارات ولايه البحر الاحمر قامت بالقاء
القبض على مجموعه من المهربين
وتم القاء القبض على اسلحه وذخائر بحسب
المصدر العسكري الذي تحدث للجزيره واكد ان
هذه
الاسلحه والذخاء والذخائر كان يفترض ان
يتم تسليمها لمن وصفهم بالمتمردين
هذه تم القاء القبض عليها في منطقه سواكن
جنوب ولايه البحر الاحمر هذه اذا التطورات
الميدانيه فيما يتعلق بالوضع الانساني
طبعا يتفاقم الوضع الانساني كلما مر يوم
والحرب الان تجاوزت الخمسه اسابيع ونعم في
ظل استمرار هذه المعاناه التي يعانيها
المواطنون هنا سنعرف المزيد لاحقا شكرا لك
اسامه السيد احمد كنت معنا من شرق الخرطوم